I know barely anything like it like a
shoelace okay look at that perfect will
it be muffled or anything okay all right
summer hey summer where you from I'm
from San Francisco and tell me family
yes I did you're good kid
thank you bad kid got a lot of trouble
don't want to trouble I was grounded a
lot but just as I looked like a sneak
out I had like that great steel just
things like I don't think too crazy um
but yeah I did it so like two days
before or like a day before graduation I
had my cap and everything but I was
really bad at math so me failing my math
final
basically I just couldn't graduate so I
was super devastated super sad but I did
end up going to Adult School to get my
actual diploma not my GED
GED so but I never really cared for
school life like the things that they
were teaching I didn't really I didn't
care about any of them like I was
obviously gonna like art ceramics all
like the fun classes but I was gonna
English too but like you know like just
the harder classes I just was so it
never did my homework never really took
notes yeah so and then after high school
whatever where'd you go
after high school where did I go um I
moved on my mom's house like three days
after I turned 18 so today my boyfriend
went with him for three years and that
was cool and stuff but you got 20 right
before 2021 yeah I kind of just left him
and then started doing my own thing but
it was your own thing in sales so I got
into porn so I um I've stripped a little
throughout those three years
if me and him were just not working out
and I'd go stay somewhere else I'd like
let me just gonna strip really quick and
Simon yeah make some money um it was fun
it was exciting but it was like very it
was like hard for me it's a lot of like
physical work there's days where you may
not get paid that well it was just a lot
you know I'm coming from someone that
has had jobs but never really had to
have a job it was like it was like
what's the word it was just frustrating
see I got into porn and yeah it was it
was cool you know that's when you're the
new girl there's a lot of a lot of work
for you I was turning a lot down to just
cuz I was like trying to can't kind of
keep it a secret and like maintain an
image just in case like it like my
parents found out or like my ex found
out and yeah so I mean so I haven't shot
that much as of now I don't know why I
really don't know why I mean I'm
shooting a little bit more but that's
why I'm kind of going back and forth
between like dancing or like webcaming
you know everything within that industry
but I heard these days it's just kind of
hard for everyone to make money just off
of porn alone just because of uh you
know all the pirating and all these
other sites yeah it's you don't really
know one really sells DVDs anymore
everything is online so therefore a lot
of stuff gets leaked my stuff's been
leaked I can like look myself up and
I'll see like people like screen
recording like see you have to water
more it's just it's it's it kind of
sucks but it's kind of cool if you know
how to you know how to kind of play the
game and you're tech savvy I guess what
are the best things and the worst things
about working in the sex industry um I
think some of the best things are just
like the independence and the freedom
you get of kind of just like you know
like today I'm just okay I got nothing
going on you know I may have something
going on later tonight but let me just
you know like the freedom I could never
really see myself working a nine-to-five
again just because I love the
flexibility that maybe I guess the money
when things are going good because for
instance at a regular job you're not
gonna make
you know a thousand or something today
you're not and that's also the problem
to where it's like I can't see myself
working regular job again because it's
like I'd be like this is it this is my
jacket you know but so some of the worst
things I think are just like the way you
get perceived if you're not a stronger
person or you don't have a tougher skin
it can be very like detrimental to your
mental health it can be very hard in
your body like I said your mental health
your relationships outside of the
industry like I really don't think I'll
have a boyfriend for a while which is
I'm totally fine with that now because
I've been in like a serial relationship
and stuff but yeah it's it that can some
people can't handle that you know your
family may like isolate you may look at
you differently in my family it's kind
of like whole she's making her own money
be safe oh yeah yeah some some unrelated
person was like is this such an
exception I'm like weirdo why are you
you know can we focus on the fact that
he's like watching me and not you know
I'm like I'm an adult I'm like twenty
two years old like I can't make my own
and I'm safe and I'm I'm doing pretty
well I live in the valley I don't have
any roommates I have a nice car so I I'm
okay but everyone kind of has a stigma
that any girl that's in this industry is
like being like sex trafficked oh she
has a pimp and it's like not really like
I'm just like a normal girl that likes
to make place to just you know what I
mean I'm open with my sexuality I always
kind of like was like a not a sexual
person but it's like I was always using
my image somehow to get me somewhere and
I was like well why not get paid for it
so you know but yeah so my parents know
and I'm my mom was like is this how you
were doing in Miami when you told me you
were modeling and I'm like yeah like
that was what I was doing cuz I remember
I come home I leave with like no makeup
and I'd either come home with no makeup
again or I just I look like really tired
and exhausted and like my hair would
obviously not be perfectly straight
anymore just alright come home at like
10:00 at night after leaving at like
7:00 a.m. or 10:00 a.m. so I don't know
but I think like now like she's just
honestly glad that like I'm keeping her
the loop you know cuz growing up like me
being in trouble a lot I wasn't really
like and like I hate my mom and Bulova
but now it's like I really I'm just
grateful dot she's just like hey like
what's going on with that and I'll tell
her you know and she's not like a mile
out to cuz she's not a [ __ ] about it
you know what I mean I've heard about
girls getting like this owned or like
just stuff like that and I'm like I'm
really grateful for that I don't have to
go it through that because it would
really suck you know drugs things you
play around I smoke weed I like to drink
I like to drink wine and I'll go out on
the weekends have my little you know
tequila great for like no because I feel
like like me living alone and you know
having to like always have a good head
on my shoulders I can't afford to like
not be on my a-game you know I actually
stopped smoking weed a lot because it
would make me just like eat a lot of
food and like me being kind of naked all
the time that was not you know and it's
just I just I I go through my phases but
you know I think I'm just also growing
up to where I'm I can this isn't really
beneficial for me to like smoke weed all
day or drink wine all day I'm like you
know what I mean so don't get me wrong
I'll probably get a cocktail after this
why not for lunch you don't mean but
like yeah there are a lot of girls who
do whatever they have to do like I
believe in doing whatever you have to do
to make your money and to get by in life
as long as you're safe but to each his
own
but I just also look a little scared of
like being here in LA like you never
know like you can't just take drugs from
anybody and I'd rather just be safe and
like not do anything at all or you know
so I'll go to the dispensary and get my
weed I don't buy street leader you know
like I remember one time I I guess I
like blacked out the second time ever
first I was in high school I thought it
was roofie because like I left my drink
unattended if like the first time ever I
always always always always cuz I go out
young attractive girl cover my drink or
just bring it with me or just leave it
there finish it leave it and get another
one
and I asked for the bartender keeping me
another one she's like fine I like being
a [ __ ] and I'm like do you not realize
how many guys are here that I could just
pop something in my drink like she liked
that so yeah I don't know but I had pre
gamed with wine at my apartment that I
went out was to doing shots of tequila
so I guess I did walk out my friends
like you're fine
like you don't member you throw up in
the uber and I'm like what's like just
stuff like that I don't like happening
cuz I find out remember it's like I
don't want to embarrass myself I don't
put myself in danger stuff like that
like I watch a lot of like crime TV so
kind of scare myself into you know not
doing things like that yeah yeah it's
it's pretty like depressing because like
for me not shoot it's not depressing all
the time there was a point where I was
like why am I not getting any work like
why are these other girls getting work
and I'm not like aren't I pretty RN I
don't I have the look and like so I
would go through like changing my hair
changing my makeup like changing
everything and if so wouldn't works so
it would there was a point like that's
when I was smoking weed everyday and
like you can win every day and just
unhealthy just like I was also in like a
toxic relationship just like I was not
happy and I just feel like I was living
in Vegas and so me moving to LA I kind
of just gave me like a different hope
like I was just like look like I'm here
I'm gonna make the best of it I was just
like I can't live like that like no
one's ever gonna book me if I am NOT
taking care of myself so it was just it
made me just feel really bad you know
made me feel like I just really down but
you know my thing was let me take
advantage of the new technology like the
premium snapchat the only fans that
swipe up features on Instagram and not
focus so much on doing porn that's when
I got back into the the stripping
because that also boosted my self-esteem
because I knew I was one of the
prettiest girls at the club and it
wasn't just my look it was just I was
friendly I was bubbly I'm not I don't
I'm not the best at the pole you know
how I'll show you dance when I have to
but like it's like me like not focusing
or not a hundred percent and like
putting my energy into something that I
could still make money off of that could
boost my self-esteem make me feel sexy
so that definitely helped me and then
not being in the house all the time like
I have all these little outfits just
sitting there I'm like let me like go
and be like ain't getting get some
compliments you know what I mean and get
paid for it you know because when you're
sitting there and seeing all these other
girls getting booked it I'm like and no
offense like they're not always the
prettiest girls I had to get off my
phone I had to get off Twitter I had to
just go live life so yeah yeah so that's
why I dabble a little
and even the webcam thing like there's
always something if--like you could do
in this industry you know you can't
focus on one thing and unless you're
literally shooting like well like at
least like like six to eight times a
month at least you know and that's not
really common for like black girls I'm
realizing either which is weird because
I think we're very popular and in pop
culture these days like a lot of people
like emulate our Styles a lot of people
want to get the super tan skin and wear
a bamboo hoop earrings and like you know
what I mean get this big butts and yet
we're not getting any love and porn but
I'm like doesn't everybody want kind of
[ __ ] us you don't I mean like you know
what I mean so I don't know but it is
what it is it's life you know what are
you waiting for first ripping a rapport
I don't notice I like I like the glamor
of stripping there's a glamour to it
like I like the sparkly big heels and
like obviously these outfits and the
long just the majesticness of like if
you know like the ratchet stripper but
like Vegas stripper glam so living in
Vegas it's just like that you know there
is a glamour to it so I love that aspect
of it so I think they prefer that but
then I also love how in porn because I
modeled for three years normally before
getting into any sex work so I like the
aspect of porn where you come get your
makeup and hair done you get your pretty
girls so you like all these three photos
and then you know you're just they make
you look good most of the time unless
the scene is to make you look like like
[ __ ] you know what I mean but so I like
both but there is a that's why I go back
and forth because there's I'll always
make it glamorous because that's just
the way I like to dress and like I like
to be really girly but I do prefer poor
just because it's less work it really is
less work shirt being you have to have a
mouth piece I can be kind of shy and
reserved
like I don't bum rush a guy at the ATM
I'll kind of just sit like oh you know
what I mean and and that's kind of why I
would get a little frustrating just stop
for a while because it was way more of a
hustle it was way more of like hard work
and I'm important it's like hey centrate
come in get paints on your it go home
get [ __ ] and go home
and it sounds a little bad but it's not
it sounds a little just to be you know
fair it's not as gruesome as get [ __ ] go
home it's work but I would prefer to
just be a full-time pornstar but I don't
have that luxury right now alright so
well thank you so much for sharing no
one liked it though it's I like it I
like it I don't do many interviews and I
had people tell me like like oh she's
one of their like more articulate porn
stars and I want to see her talk more
and I'm like wow like so that does help
- that does help - just to know that you
know cuz no one really hears me talk
unless I'm reading like a filthy scripts
like you ever saying [ __ ] me you know
what I mean
you